wer weiß schon freuen
worden sind
wer weiß schon
morgen sind immer wieder alles neu
beginnt hat möglichen wir sind wieder 16
heute an silvester der 31 12 ist dafür
da richtig party zu machen und mehrmals
vorbereitet so ein paar bräuche wie wir
sie in deutschland haben ein herrlicher
spaß für jung und alt überraschung
stimmung spannung partykracher nummer
eins in deutschland ist bleigießen man
schmilzt einfach dass bei menschen ist
gibt man einfach in die kasse scheine
vor
danach schaut man noch die form ist
eingenommen hat und kann es dann deuten
da gibt es mir sorgen für das sind alles
dinge die glück bringen
im neuen jahr ist es doch eindeutig ist
das feuer so was wie die olympische
fackel naja du hast an der erleuchtung
man kann wirklich alles rein sortieren
was man will
du bist einfach lecker am nächsten jahr
ich bin total an silvester typische
fehler hätte ich es gerne raketen ab
wenn wir spaß haben und ich glaube wenn
auch nicht die 1
wir müssen jetzt nach links wir gehen
jetzt zum ferrari an
da fahren sie dann die harten geschütze
auf
also normalerweise wenn der sommer ist
die wiesn und genau heute zu bulgarien
wo was los ist er war maskiert im
plätzchen suchen davor schaut auf die
uhr es ist trainer vor zwölf
wenn es dann zwölf ist dann nimmt man
einfach den nächsten der neben sich
steht in den arm und wünscht ihnen ein
gutes neues jahr
das macht man so das ich so liebe deinen
nächsten
ich meinerseits gegen die raketen nach
oben
aber andererseits darunter das ganze
zeug machen haben